Dork or he has to be transported by the
Marshal Service
business manager
well we'll see what the discovery is
they could say whatever they want about
things going on and and I haven't seen
any evidence yet so I don't really feel
comfortable saying anything about it I
haven't seen any evidence that he did
anything like that they also in that
same indictment allege that he paid a
large sum of money to his business
manager to cover things up which I know
was a settlement of a lawsuit when the
business manager sued him so I'm not
sure how much credibility to put in any
of those allegations I'm sorry what well
who says they're a victim I mean you
know when people look at look at their
there are people who cook really right
there sit there six new ones we'll see
what the proof is they've charged them
in New York with enticing people and
encouraging people to have sex with them
I don't think people accidentally have
sex so I'm not really sure what the
criminal activity is there well well
there but it's not underage these are
adults that they've said in that
indictment they they have counts counts
in that indictment where they say that
he encouraged and entice adults to have
sex with him and it does say that and I
haven't seen any evidence of any of that
I mean people can say whatever they want
what we hold on one side what we know is
we know that all of these charges are
decades old and and all of a sudden
people are coming forward and we see
what happens in those cases all the time
and we're gonna wait and see what
happens with the evidence we're gonna
wait and see what proof they have we're
gonna challenge the proof and we're
gonna press on because he didn't do
anything wrong
yes
I have no idea I have note that that's
part of the problem is we've got John
Doe 1 and John Doe 2 a nun name 1 and
individual a and B and we don't know who
these people are so you know I I don't
know who they are I don't know who they
are
prosecutors I know exactly what you know
I have a I have an indictment that is
allegations that alleges somebody did
something wrong that's all I have is
allegations he's presumed innocent we
believe he's innocent we're gonna fight
to prove he's innocent
right well how would you feel about
spending the weekend behind bars I mean
no one ever wants to be behind bars
unfortunately under federal law if the
government requests in certain kinds of
cases they can hold you and delay your
bail hearing for 3 to 5 days so that's
what what's going on here 3 to 5
business days
I mean I'm amazed that he hasn't had a
complete breakdown in the face of all of
this and the pressure and and the
pressure on his career is basically in
many respects its collapsed he hasn't
been able dat to her he keeps finding
himself getting charged with things I
think it's a it's the worst case of
piling on I've ever seen let us do a
case let's get to the bottom of it let's
get to the truth and and then let's move
on what would he say he wouldn't say
anything to him I so I bet so I've had
people who but he's out on bond on the
crook County charges so as long as that
bond remains in in full force they can't
hold him in the Cook County Jail but I
bet I've had people with state and
federal charges
sometimes they're held in federal
custody and they bring him to state
sometimes they're in state custody and
they bring in a Fed I don't have any
control over that well so so bail in the
federal system is rarely monetarily
based the question is whether there is
there are conditions would which would
assure that he would appear on the
charges so the question for the judge is
can he he formulate conditions I think
there certainly our conditions look if
the man was gonna flee to avoid
prosecution
he'd have been long gone
you mean the guy in Pennsylvania the guy
who was cleaning his garage and and and
you know we never heard from again
III don't put any any credence of what
that guy said I think I think it's an
abuse of the RICO laws you know saying
saying that that someone was a musician
and that there was backstage parties and
there were groupies and so forth that's
essentially what it is that they've
charged as a racketeering enterprise I
think it's a scary use of that law I
think it's unfair piling on I think
that's a fair statement yes
it's gonna have to
so we're still putting together
whoever's going to be we didn't get any
advance notice of any of this had they
given us notice certainly mr. Kelly
would have come just as he did in state
court and voluntarily turned himself in
he was out walking his dog last night as
you know when he was arrested we had
people in place in case he was charged
here for gun on the New York situation
we'll work on the New York situation I
know I know Doug Doug was in a
motorcycle accident so that's why he
hasn't been around with the dog I think
they gave the dog to one of his friends
but the dog's name is belief believe the
dog's name is belief
that would be between me and mr. Kelly I
was said I mean I got there moments
after he's arrested they were I would
commend and I I'm not someone who often
commends law enforcement but I would
commend them they were very discreet
very quiet very polite they didn't make
a big hub of or anything like that also
mr. Kelly was totally cooperative with
them you've seen how he acts in court he
has great respect for the law
enforcement officials he has great
respect for prosecutors great respect
for the judiciary
I think they cuff everybody when they
when they arrest them I think there were
people from New York City I don't I
don't know who was they had badges I
didn't write down who was state who was
federal who was Chicago and and who was
not they I try and limit my interaction
all right everyone have a nice weekend